products
foreign
good morning good morning
you again
good morning good morning well we will
continue discussing about
they go in Ukraine with the Ministers of
Defense they are important issues first
we have the board of the European
Defense Agency and we will welcome
Denmark new member
we will have a look at the new Pesco
projects 11 new Pesco projects which is
an important way of increasing the
cooperation between our armies
and then after the board of European
Defense Agency we'll go to the defense
Minister's Council
we will look at the ammunition
deliveries
I will give you after the meeting a
concrete data about the two tracks which
are under my responsibility I think I
will be able to provide good news things
are on track and we are delivering but
let me give the data after
then we have a look at the European
peace facility all together at that
moment
thanks to the European peace facility we
have mobilized 10 billion euros of
Military Support to Ukraine 10 billion
the member research has presented us
bills by 10 billion which is much more
than expected with 3.5 billions of
European peace facilities we have
triggered 10 billions of Military
Support
and this Military Support has to
continue I am happy that
finally the the training of the pilot
for the F-16 as I started
in several countries it will take a time
but sooner the better
and
the the open this door for the provision
of a Jetta which is you know it's always
the same thing with this cars at the
beginning everybody is reluctant and at
the end with the little part with the
F-16 at the end the decision comes to
provide this military support because
it's absolutely needed in order to
Ukrainian continue the funding so it's
going to be a profitable meeting I give
you concrete data
we have a message
you know that directly affected uh you
have so many issue right now the second
Brown and Turkish election can you give
me elections where
opinions
about what
ah no no we are not going to talk about
the Turkish election today territory not
available
unhappily it is not an appearance this
is a reality
but we will we will uh we'll solve it we
cannot brought the support to Ukraine
now I'm sure it will be the block
yeah we are on track and I will provide
concrete figures
we are on track
you said training has already started in
several countries which countries are
you talking about for example in Poland
it already started against Iran you have
decided could you tell me details please
today we have this agendas
initiative from denim do you think
because they
discussions
for ammunition production do you have
solution for this we'll take after
sometimes
foreign
[Music]
greetings from Finland good to be here
with the
good friends from European Union
we are discussing of course how to help
Ukraine in this horrible War
how to speed up production of Defense
material in in Europe
also
I have to say that it's good to have a
Denmark also in European Defense
agencies meeting this morning
General hasn't been there before
that's a good step forward
as you might know we have in Finland the
governmental negotiations are ongoing at
the moment
it might take some weeks then we get the
new government in Finland
but I'm sure that the line of foreign
security policy will stand and and we
keep assisting Ukraine also in the in
the future thank you
[Music]
foreign
obsession
um
and software
tonight
[Music]
that is
um
do you know how many F-16
well perhaps in English I'm really very
happy that last Friday we got the green
light from Washington DC on the training
of the Ukrainian pilots on fighter jets
on f-16s that means that we can continue
and also finalize the plans that we're
making with Denmark and other allies to
start these these trainings and of
course that is the first step that you
have to take you have to have pilots who
know how to fight these fly these these
planes and the next step would be also
looking to the planes themselves but as
I said that is the next step so this is
the first step that we're going to take
we will continue discussing with our
allies and with countries that might
have f-16s available about that next
step but that's not on the table right
now that is in the next phase
we have we're working on the concrete
timeline for starting the trainings and
we feel it's important to do that as
soon as possible well we did need the
green light from from Washington DC uh
and it is a co-effort with Denmark
Belgium UK and other allies so a
coordinated effort but we we will speed
up now that we know that we have the
green light okay preparations
yes we have we we have been we've been
talking to our allies we've been
thinking through how this could be done
uh always said that and always talked of
course also to the United States knowing
that we needed that we and I to make
this possible and that means that we're
now in the next phase
well I wouldn't put that timeline on it
now but it is important I think that now
that we know that we can start that we
also make it happen as soon as possible
yes Denmark and also Belgium is also on
board UK
is joining this this jet Coalition and
of course now we're all starting talking
with other countries because now that we
have this green night from Washington it
means that other countries could join
this Coalition also those that don't
have F-16
UK for instance doesn't have f-16s but
they support the Coalition and are
willing to contribute also and with
other means Minister on ammunition do
you think this one million is still a
realistic Target we're hearing that not
much has come from track one of the plan
track two was held up by wrangling over
the origin of the production is that
still a realistic Target of what needs
to be done if you're to get it or even
comfortable well I think the most
important is what does Ukraine need and
Ukraine needs ammunition and a lot of it
and that is why I'm happy that we have
these these two tracks and we also make
I must make sure that we deliver on bus
tracks but is it a realistic number one
million within 12 months well once again
the ammunition that Ukraine needs would
be my goal and this is a substantial
contribution to it and it's not the only
contribution but it has to be
substantial
no I think that what what you Ukraine
knows that it can count on us on its
partner countries from the European
Union and we must show Ukraine that they
also actually can rely upon us so if we
promise them to help them with the
ammunition we must deliver on that and I
think that is something that Netherlands
and other countries are going to stress
today
well we the ammunition deal that we have
is especially on the 155 we know of
course that the production of ammunition
and defense industry is struggling to
increase the production and there are
many factors that are relevant for that
increase so labor also
the the relevant raw materials that you
need so that has to be on the table and
that is something that also the
commission and also member says have to
talk to their Industries about
uh well so far the countries that have
been talking to each other are apart
from the United States Netherlands
Denmark Belgium and UK but I'm confident
that others will join
well I don't have a specific goal for
that but I'm sure that all as well thank
you do you think it's an urgent issue
the air Fighters uh in the battlefield
or do you or there is more stuff that is
more urgent for Ukraine at this stage
well at this stage and the the war that
we see is happening every day of course
the ammunition is I think the most
urgent but at the same time the Ukraine
armed forces are transitioning into new
weapon systems that come from Europe and
the United States and that is also
urgent I'm afraid that we we don't know
how long this war will be going on but
we know that Ukraine will be have to be
able to defend itself for as long as it
takes in the war and also after the war
so investing in for instance training
Ukrainian pilots on the f-16s is of
course something that will take effect
later on later on in the war or after
the war but it's always a good
investment because it's an investment in
the security of
Ukraine's life that will if you will be
delivered to well we're now we're
talking about training the pilot so
we're not yet talking about uh the the
planes themselves but of course it makes
sense that countries like the
Netherlands were transitioning from F-16
to f-35s other countries that will talk
about that and look into the
possibilities and when will that happen
first we start with the training and at
the same time we continue the talks with
our allies to see what it's possible
okay thank you thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
content
foreign
Adventure
pockets are in this
exercise
[Music]
well I never heard that before at least
not during the last month that we do too
less and too late especially Germany is
really in much in front ventilinsky was
in Germany last week he confirmed that
very very clearly he said Germany is the
most important supporter of Ukraine
after us after the U.S so this is my
answer to your question
we don't see if it's about it
and foreign
[Music]
something well this is this is not an
topic not the topic on the agenda of
this day but of course we are talking
about that frequently and regularly and
it is necessary to be aware what's going
on there and to be to stick close
together uh to to fight against that of
course
[Music]
images
money Target online for several laws
which is like the basic confidence for
ammunition production and Germany is one
of the producers are you talking about
the shortage do you have anything of
course we are talking about we have been
talking about that issue and the
solutions we might find for it at least
for several weeks I think and we are
talking with with the international
Enterprises with the international
alliances we can we can build for
producing more of that is
listen there's some links of the
evacuation of Sudan
is there a lot of need about assets or
more organization to apply for the
organizations that we have with the
french-based UK I think there was a very
very good cooperation between especially
Germany France Great Britain and the
United States and some others and it
really worked very very very well we
didn't have any serious problems we had
all assets we needed we had supports in
Jordan and in other places that we had
everything we needed and we succeeded in
evacuate our people in a very very short
time
well France has a lot of bodies in in
Djibouti and then other and the U.S as
far as I'm informed too I think we need
allies and friends all over the world
but we can't we can't just build them we
have to find them we have to build trust
and I think it worked in Sudan and in
the neighborhood of Sudan otherwise we
wouldn't have been so successful
okay thank you very much
yes
an investigations
[Music]
Julio and Santander foreign
Espana
[Music]
gracias
good morning good morning
the topic of today's meeting is about
the openness at the same time and the
security of knowledge and research
knowledge which I think is very
important in the current geopolitical
situation as well we have lots of
insecurities about the use and abuse of
the scientific knowledge and scientific
infrastructure of Europe as well and of
course it's very heavily affected by the
ongoing war against Ukraine and I would
like to stress here that it's very
important and we consider in Estonia
it's very important that European
commission has taken steps to integrate
Ukraine into the European research area
by opening The Horizon office in Kiev
soon and Ukraine needs all our support
and Estonia is very much ready to help
Ukraine in restructuring its research
because we have done this since 1991
quite successfully and we have
experience in that and last but not
least I think we all member states need
to acknowledge that it's our duty to
help very soon as soon as possible to
stop this war and in this situation all
sanctions that we have agreed on against
Russia are important to hold including
the sanctions against cooperating with
Russia research and Russian researchers
so thank you very much
we'll just first of all to say that I'm
looking forward to the European Defense
ministers meeting today obviously the
key issue on the agenda is the terrible
war in Ukraine and the
continuing
Invasion by Russia in in an attack on
the people of Ukraine and we have to do
everything we possibly can to continue
to support the people of Ukraine in
their self-defense and then resisting
Russian aggression and also then to look
at ongoing challenges and threats to
European Union security and we're
particularly looking forward to updates
on issues like cyber security
Maritime security and hybrid threats as
well so we're looking forward to the
debate and the engagement today with
other ministers thank you very much
indeed
a couple of issues outstanding there one
Hungary holding up for the allocation of
the next transit Aid and how do you feel
about that how important is that well I
think it's very important that that
Transylvania is released and I think
clearly uh the reasons that have been
put forward I don't think are
proportionate in any way to justify the
the
um
lack of sanction if you like or the
decision not to facilitate the passage
through of this package so I think the
issues are capable of being resolved
they should be resolved and the peace
facility should be progressed as quickly
as possible
thank you
good morning good morning everyone
we're looking forward to this day we're
going to have a really important
discussions and we are going to adopt
the calcium conclusions regarding
scholar publishing and we are a pro and
open system that makes it possible for
researchers to reach more people and to
have an open science system
we're also going to have a council
conclusions regarding open space and the
fair access to space which is of course
a very important issue for Europe but
the world doesn't hold this has been
really important issues for the Swedish
presidency and we are welcoming the
discussions and we're looking forward to
this